تعتبر بيلاروسيا
أرضًا من الغابات والبحيرات
والأنهار
وأه في بعض الأحيان نعتبر حتى
رئتي أوروبا
وذلك لأن لدينا جزءًا كبيرًا
من أراضينا مغطاة
بالغابات وهذا هو السبب في أن إحدى الأفكار وراء
هذه الشجرة هي
أيضًا ترميز
الشجرة كرمز
لبلدنا ، شجرة المعرفة هي
النقطة المركزية لجناحنا
في منطقة الصمامات ولكن في نفس الوقت
الأهم هو أن
هذا المعرض هو شيء
يقع بالكامل تحت الموضوع الرئيسي لهذا
المعرض الذي
يوحد  العقول تخلق المستقبل
لماذا
هذا لأن
التكوين يتكون من
معروضات
تم إنشاؤها بواسطة الطلاب
في المدرسة ، هذه معروضات هي
نماذج أولية للأجهزة
المستقبلية ، الشجرة هي فكرة إحدى
الفنانين البيلاروسيين وقد صنعتها
مع والدتها.
شاهد الرابط بين الأجيال ،
هذا معرض طويل جدًا يبلغ طوله 9
أمتار تقريبًا ويبلغ طوله 30 قدمًا
تقريبًا ، فالشجرة مصنوعة من خيوط
قطنية من الحبال القطنية
وجثة الشجرة عبارة عن معدن
[موسيقى
] ، تم إحضار الشجرة هنا في أجزاء
عبر البحر وتم
تجميع الرسالة التي نقدمها
للجمهور الذي يزور جناحنا
وهي
الاستثمار في المعرفة والاستثمار في التعليم
و  هذا شيء
سيساعدك في المستقبل
وسيوجهك للأشياء في المستقبل